now to this story the glamorous state
dinner honoring the French president and
his wife is helping Melania Trump become
a more visible first lady the White
House says mrs. Trump had the largest
role in planning last night's event the
first state dinner of this
administration Julianna Goldman is at
the White House Julianna good morning
good morning well you know the first
lady really has played more of a
behind-the-scenes role compared to her
predecessors but last night all eyes
were on Melania Trump in what was a
symbolic debut mixing tradition
diplomacy and glamour the first lady was
front and center at last night's state
dinner stealing the show in a sequined
gown by the French designer Chanel
before the dinner Melania Trump and her
hat turned heads as she and Brigitte
Makran visited the National Gallery of
Art the former model is the first
immigrant first lady since 1825 born in
Slovenia she's now an American citizen
and speaks several languages I have been
criticized for many commitment to
tackling this issue and I know that will
continue but it will not stop me from
doing what I know is right she's used
her platform to combat cyber bullying
and call attention to America's opioid
epidemic I'm proud of this
administration's commitment to battling
this epidemic last night's dinner capped
a week spent in the public eye hosting
the Japanese prime minister and his wife
at mar-a-lago and a trip without the
president to the funeral of former first
lady barbara Bush mrs. Trump is seems to
be very comfortable in establishing
herself as someone who's going to fit
right in with that Club Lee Berman a
former White House social secretary in
the George W Bush administration says
last night's dinner is sure to have
taken months of planning the Trump's are
very different from any other first
couple because they had no political
experience going in so the learning
curve was steeper for them and it's
taking a little longer but I feel as
Sochi is really getting the hang of it
the White House says mrs. Trump designed
every detail of last night you know she
has fewer than a dozen East Wing
staffers and they reportedly did not
call in an event planner as previous
administrations have done Gail yeah well
that's a big job you know nor what it's
like those two really nice dinner party
with flat I'm serious who are the
hostess with the mostess I'm not making
fun of that I know yeah I'm not very
good at it but you were very good and
you know what it takes to put that
together and the people that were there
say that she nailed it yeah a beautiful
table beautiful flowers yeah well it
does and the French pay attention to
that kind of thing that's moving for
their yeah attention but that worked
Julianna thank you